ist Nina Hagen ein ziemlicher Styling
Unfall mit ihrem Pippi Langstrumpf
Zöpfen das sind die Fragen die wir
stellen im Fragen Lotte wie immer
ziemlich gemein und aber auch ganz nett
wenn er keins verpassen wollt abonnieren
nicht vergessen und jetzt reingucken
jetzt kommt ein kleines finale Pass auf
das sind böse und harmlose fragen wir
haben nur eine Minute du musst ganz
schnell an die roten sind böse gemeine
Fragen also wir haben wirklich uns äh
überlegt wie wir dich ärgern können
also lass uns jetzt nicht enttäuschen
einfach abdrehen pass auf so abdrehen
zack zack
hast du eigentlich ja keine Beratung
beim Styling
hast du eigentlich gar keine Beratung
das unterstellt dass du schlecht gestylt
bis ich meine was die Augen so dunkel
und die Lippen ganz rot und hast immer
so oben wie viel Jahren seit 40 Jahren
und als Kind habe ich auch oft und
ich fühle mich damit frisch
die Grünen sind sehr nett
du wirst immer
tiefer auch Gott jetzt schleimt sich
jemand ein natürliches
ich glaube nur vor vielen vielen Jahren
hast mal ein zwei Jahre hintereinander
ein Album veröffentlicht und jetzt
direkt wieder ja aber dazwischen hast du
immer so zwei drei Jahre aber pass mal
auf die Seite so es war so ich wollte ja
gerne in deutschsprachiges Album machen
und habe zehn Jahre lang trinken geputzt
das wollte keine eins haben und ähm es
ist wirklich nicht meine Schuld also
noch eine zum Abschluss
oh liebe eine böse mach mal erstmal die
eine böse noch
hier kommt deine und unglaubliche
Kreativität naja aus meiner Liebe zum
Leben und aus meiner Angst los ich da
unten aus meinem Vertrauen und meinem
tiefen Glauben dass das Leben ewig sein
wird ist das Leben ist ewig wenn wir mal
hier unseren irdischen Körper verlassen
und tschüss
500 ich habe 500 Platten DVDs CDs
wahnsinn ich glaube es gibt kaum eine
Sängerin und Sänger in Deutschland der
so viel gemacht hat wie du
echt aber das ist ja nicht die Frage wie
viel man gemacht hat sondern ob es Spaß
gemacht hat und ob es Qualität ist ja
nicht irgendwie alles hoch musikalisch
so pass auf oh das ist sehr privat ich
weiß nicht ob das beantworten willst
wie viele Partner hattest du in deinem
Leben
oder was machst
ja es geht
ich weiß es geht uns überhaupt nicht
sagen
aber ich habe doch darüber mein Buch
auch ganz ehrlich geschrieben und auch
in meinem profitabel
da haben auch viele viele von meinen
lebensabschnittspartnern sind dort zu
Wort gekommen und haben noch über mich
ausgeht die verstehen sich immer nur mit
dir ja natürlich
Dänen lügen nicht der
aber
ich bin ja ich bin ja sowieso vom Beruf
Nonne und dass ich zwischendurch
verheiratet war das war ich konnte ja
nichts dafür
weil der Mensch versucht ja nach der
Liebe zu suchen und die Liebe zu finden
und manchmal
ist es dann auch gar keine Liebe gewesen
oder hat versucht Liebe zu sein oder zu
werden und es ist nicht geworden aber
die Liebe
die hört nie auf und und von der Liebe
gibts mehr als genug man braucht nicht
denken es gibt keine Liebe mehr und man
muss jetzt sofort alles auf einmal
verlieben
ist genug Liebe für alle da